queremos evaluar la integral definida
desde 1 hasta 8 de 2cm que multiplican a
la raíz cúbica de x de x y ahora lo
primero que vamos a hacer es ver que
esto es lo mismo que la integral
definida desde menos 1 hasta 8 de 12 y
en lugar de poner la raíz cúbica de x
voy a poner x elevado a la intención de
x y ahora si queremos sacar la derivada
de lo que tenemos adentro solo vamos a
hacer básicamente la regla de las
potencias las integrales o mejor dicho
es lo contrario de las reglas de las
potencias para las derivadas donde
aumentamos este exponente en 1 y luego
lo dividimos entre es exponente
aumentado entonces esto va a ser igual a
2 cm x elevado a la un tercio más 1 y
luego vamos a dividir todo entre un
tercio más uno entonces cuánto es un
tercio más uno bueno eso es lo mismo que
cuatro tercios un tercio más tres
tercios son cuatro tercios entonces
podría escribirlo así como 12 x elevado
a la 4 tercios
entre cuatro tercios y ahora voy a
evaluar estos límites de integración
recuerda que lo que tenemos que hacer es
evaluar lo primero en 8 ya eso le vamos
a restar la evaluación en 1 así que a
que va a ser igual esto bueno permiten
simplificar de un poco cuánto es 12
dividido entre cuatro tercios lo voy a
poner aquí 12 dividido entre cuatro
tercios
es lo mismo que bueno 12 por el
recíproco por tres cuartos y me quedan
dividido entre 4 bueno eso es lo mismo
que 3 y 3 por 3 es 9 así que podríamos
volver a escribir esto como bueno en
lugar de todo esto voy a poner 9 que
multiplica a x elevado a la cuatro
tercios y ahora sí vamos a evaluarlo en
8 si lo evaluamos en 8 esto me va a
quedar 9 que multiplica a 8 elevado a la
cuatro tercios
a eso le vamos a restar la evaluación en
-1 que va a ser 9 que multiplica a menos
1 esto elevado a la cuatro tercios y
cuánto es 8 elevado a la cuatro tercios
bueno vamos a hacerlo por acá 8 elevado
de cuatro tercios
es lo mismo que 8 elevado a la un tercio
y esto sube es elevado a la potencia 4 y
ahora sí 8 elevado a un tercio es igual
a la raíz cúbica de 8 lo cuales dos ya
que 2 elevado al cubo es igual a 8 y
ahora si tengo 2 esto elevado a la
cuarta potencia esos 16 por lo tanto ya
puedo escribir que todo esto de aquí me
va a quedar como un 9 por 16 y ahora
cuánto es menos 1 elevado a la cuatro
tercios bueno vamos a seguir la misma
idea pero esta vez voy a cambiar la
forma en la que voy a escribir los
exponentes hay varias maneras en la que
podría hacerlo pero se me ocurre que es
más fácil pensar que esto es lo mismo
que menos 1 esto elevado la potencia 4 y
luego sacar la raíz cúbica de eso
nos quedan menos una elevado a la 4 es
lo mismo que uno y si esto lo elevamos a
la potencia un tercio es simplemente uno
entonces todo esto the climb simplemente
se reduce a nueve por uno entonces esto
va a ser igual a nueve que multiplica a
16 menos 9 que multiplica a 1 y esto va
a ser lo mismo que 9 que multiplica 15
tenemos 16 veces 9 ya eso le quitamos
una vez 9 entonces nos quedan 15 veces 9
y cuantos 9 por 15 bueno es lo mismo que
90 más 45 y si sumamos 90 más 45 eso es
igual a 135 y qué creés ya terminamos